الصراع بين واشنطن مشاهدينا وبكين يمتد
الى تيك توك هو بكل تاكيد واستمخاوف
لاساءه استخدام بيانات المستخدمين من قبل
المسؤولين الصينيين قد يفقد التطبيق
مستخدميه يقدر عددهم ب 150 مليون شخص داخل
الولايات المتحده وسط دعوات متزايده لحظر
التطبيق لاسباب تتعلق بالامن القومي
الامريكي يامل شو تشي تشو وهو الرئيس
التنفيذي للشركه يامل في تهدئه المخاوف
الامريكيه في شهاده مرتقبه غدا امام لجنه
الطاقه والتجاره بمجلس النواب الامريكي
والتي سبقها بالتاكيد على ان التطبيق
المملوك للصينيين لم ولن يشارك بيانات
مستخدميه الامريكيين مع الحكومه الصينيه
اذا ما فشلت شيتشو في اقناع الكونجرس
سيكون امامه خيارين كلاهما او خياران
كلاهما سيء اما الحظر او الاجبار على
البيع القصري طبعا وفقا لشهاده مكتوبه
نشرت مسبقا سيقول تشيت شو امام الكونجرس
ان تيك توك لم يشارك مطلقا
يتلقى طلبا لمشاركه بيانات المستخدمين مع
الحكومه الصينيه
ولن يولي مثل هذا الطلب اهتمام اذا تلقاه
وطبعا في اي وقت من الاوقات يتخوف منتقده
تيك توك من امكان تسريب بيانات المستخدمين
الى الحكومه الصينيه اطلقوا ايضا دعوات
متزايده للمشرعين الامريكيين لحظره ولم
تقف الحكومه الصينيه متفرجه حيث دخلت على
الخط دعت واشنطن لتوقفي عن قمع الشركات
الاجنبيه مؤكده ان واشنطن لم تقدم ادله
على ان تيك توك يهدد الامن القومي